You ready for an adventure
2023 on Disney plus it's quite a year 's this is
this is new faces we are expecting someone
else and some familiar ones too hang on like
this handsome fellow all over the dark don't you
think there's only one place that's home to all
of this and so much more Disney Plus. Welcome back
everyone it's Charlie we're burdened with glorious
footage there's a bunch of new trailer footage
to break down from a couple different Series so
this Loki season 2 footage new footage from Secret
Invasion which is also coming at the beginning of
next year new footage of the Mandalorian season 3
and from the Ahsoka series if you're brand new to
the channel I'll be doing videos for all those
series just like I do for all the other Marvel
Disney plus series Star Wars Disney plus Series
be sure to subscribe to get everything starting
with a Loki season 2 trailer footage some of the
scenes are from the season 2 trailer that they
released at d23 they didn't make it public but I
did do like a full breakdown of all the footage in
the longer trailer on my channel a couple months
ago in the first scene you see Sylvie inside a
classic vinyl record shop like an old-timey 70s
final record shop listening to music because
she's hiding out in a 1970s looking McDonald's
in all these scenes pretending like she's just
a normal worker there Loki winds up inadvertently
finding her there at that McDonald's because he's
also there chasing down a new Nexus event which
is related to some of the other footage that they
included in this remember Sylvia this whole
thing is that she hides out inside apocalypse
level events because the TVA can't track her there
meaning something terrible might wind up happening
at this McDonald's really soon so rip to all these
other people here but this is meant to play like
their big reunion like he wasn't here looking for
her he was here to stop a Nexus event and she just
happened to be here like oh wow it's you remember
when we killed Kang at the end of last season and
freed all the different timelines and started the
Kang Multiverse War again yeah that Old Chestnut
the second scenes are from Loki inside the tva's
cafeteria or one of their many cafeterias that's
designed like a classic auto mat like a classic
British Auto map because everything in the TVA
has this very particular design style that makes
it look old-timey even though technically nothing
actually ages in the TVA because of the way the
Kang Controls the flow of time in there because
we're talking about Loki you may also remember
that Deadpool 3 is going to feature the TVA and
Mobius some of the other TVA related characters I
don't know that Loki himself will be in Deadpool
3 that'd be amazing but the TVA is a big plot
point because Deadpool Kills the Marvel Universe
but they're doing it in a slightly different way
Deadpool kills the fox Marvel Universe timeline
so basically Mobius the other TVA agents wind up
arresting Deadpool and Wolverine is along for that
ride new was a bad idea giving him Cable's time
travel device I know there's all kinds of theories
about the TVA secretly being inside the quantum
realm because of what's happening with Kang the
Conqueror in the Ant-Man 3 quanta media trailer
but that's not exactly what's going on now he does
use quantum energy to power all of his technology
so it's similar to what's happening in Ant-Man
quantumania but the TVA is meant to exist sort
of on its own little pocket Dimension outside the
main timeline so it is protected from changes to
the timeline itself that's why they had the whole
joke about the Infinity Stones from different
realities not working in the TVA like oh we just
pass them around they're just like paperweights
we keep them in this drawer here just a bunch of
junk because the Infinity Stones only work inside
their own realities in the scene he's talking to
Mobius about their current predicament it's meant
to be a parallel for their scenes during season
one in that version of the tba's launch room
where they work through the problem how to find
Sylvie before they knew who or what Sylvie was
the next scene is of Loki in another new room in
the TVA trying to explain something being held
at the mercy of some other attendant here like
some of the receptionists and it's just meant
to be a funny scene of him getting exasperated
with someone who's not listening to him like the
assistant in someone's office who just forces you
to wait for some important meeting you're there
for the next much bigger scene is in the back
alley of a special theater where they've come
to stop a new Nexus event involving the zaniac
character from Marvel Comics I've already done a
longer video about this because we saw a bunch of
footage from this and there's a whole bunch of
Easter eggs for all the fake movies inside the
Marvel Universe but the reason why they're dressed
in tuxedos that look like that all old-timey is
because this is taking place in the 1970s London
like they actually go back in time to stop the
Nexus event and it's at this movie premiere
at this London theater and in the scene you
probably recognize Loki is using the same magic
trick that he used in the first Avengers movie
to duplicate himself with Illusions and Mobius
is just making fun of him like isn't this a bit
much you're like being a bit showy even though
this totally low-key style to be super showy and
over the top because the movie that's premiering
here is the zaniac movie which itself is a comic
book character so it's like a reference within a
reference within a reference so it's a very meta
episode because zaniac himself is sort of like
a parody on comic book characters inside the MCU
and at this particular movie theater there's
a bunch of those fake in Universe MCU movies
that themselves are references to other real-life
Marvel movies I'll post a link in the description
for my other longer video on that because there
are a lot of Easter eggs in different parts of the
scene that they didn't include in the trailer like
kingo's original movie is also playing at this
movie theater because this is in the 1970s then
they're in another new room revealing the K Quan
from everything everywhere all at once is playing
a brand new character they actually brought him on
stage during the d23 presentation like guess
who we got they said that he's playing a TV8
archivist in the room they're in just seems like
an archives room where they store really dangerous
or really important items that they don't just
outright destroy or send to the trash planet
and Loki makes in everything everywhere all at
once reference he says this is about everything
during this scene while they cut this in the
trailer and in the last scene he's falling between
buildings inside the TVA screaming the whole way
down like business as usual for Loki same as it
ever was seems like a disaster that he's totally
failing at but somehow manages to pull off a win
there's a scene of him in another new room with
someone from the TVA dressed in what looks like a
very kang-themed outfit like something similar to
what he who remains Kang was wearing at the end of
season one he also has some gold bands and purple
robes it seems like it's inspired by the Rama Tut
outfit like something from ancient Egypt and he
destroys a painting on the wall depicting the
timekeepers holding the sacred timeline in their
hands like it's a wall painting depicting the Miss
Minutes video that we saw at the beginning of
season one Loki uses one of the TVA weapons to
remove it revealing behind the wall is this giant
gold statue of Kang's face and it's kind of like
the one above rensslayer's desk in the judge's
offices during season one except that was a
wooden carving of the timekeeper's face cases but
this time it's of Kang's face like he's trying to
reveal the truth who is behind the timekeepers
it was Kang all along post all your Agatha memes
as they slowly zoom out on Kang's face you can
also see this blue head that seems like it's been
severed in the front here like it's meant to be
a parallel for season one when they cut the head
off of The Time Keeper robots and obviously lots
of questions about what's happening with Kang the
Conqueror during Loki season 2 because we're
gonna see a version of him during Ant-Man the
Wasp Quantumania what I think they might wind
up doing is explaining that it's actually the
same version of Kang and part of what they've
explained in Loki season 2 is that during the
events of the series Kang isn't actually around
controlling them the way that they think he is
like in this version of the timeline the rebooted
timeline all the agents know that Kang exists
because you see his statue in the TBA they think
they're getting all their marching orders from him
but at the end of season one when Loki shows up
they're all confused that might be because Kang
got stuck in the quantum realm and because of the
way time moves in the quantum realm for them it
seems like it just happened but when we see kang
during Ant-Man 3 Quantumania he will feel like
he's been stuck there for eons but they did say
that Jonathan Majors will show up in Loki season
2 as a version of Kang just not in the way that
you expect it like I said I think they'll try to
tie this together and be like oh he wasn't around
because he was stuck in the quantum realm it just
seems like it's been much longer for some people
based on where you're living like if you're in the
quantum realm it seems like it's been eons but if
you're living outside the quantum realm it seems
like it's only been a little while the new secret
Invasion trailer footage is of Emilia Clarke's
character talking to Nick Fury about this evil
faction of Scrolls which they also show separately
say that this is just the beginning look they're
uncovering this big conspiracy that this evil
faction of Scrolls is trying to pull off trying
to take over Earth just like comic book secret
Invasion there are rumors now that she's actually
playing talos's daughter and that's her connection
to Nick Fury in Talos like why Talos would get
involved we also see the footage of Everett Ross
helping Nick Fury but he's sneaking around because
now he's a fugitive from the law because Okoye
broke him out of federal custody at the end of the
black black panther wakanda forever movie which
they also show footage of during this trailer the
reason why they had the wakanda forever footage
in this is because the movie is coming to Disney
Plus in 2023 like this is meant to be a Disney
plus trailer of all the big stuff coming at the
beginning of the year the whole idea during that
movie is that Everett Ross was trying to help the
wakandans and Val wanted to arrest him because
they're setting her up as this bigger villain
like a dark version of Nick Fury who is now in
charge of the CIA and using that power to just go
rampant that's part of a larger plot that's going
to culminate in the Thunderbolts movie in Captain
America 4 New World Order with red Hulk when it
sounds like they're actually going to introduce a
version of the century in the Thunderbolts movie
or maybe even Squadron Supreme and now that Henry
Cavill is totally available like he got fired as
Superman he's totally available to play a Marvel
character I don't actually think that he's going
to wind up playing a dark version of Superman in
a Marvel movie like Hyperion or even the Sentry if
he does show up in a Marvel movie he probably
plays somebody completely different they even
have new footage of the Mandalorian season 3
trailer in here there's supposed to be another
new trailer coming next week like the week of
Christmas as of me posting this video then they
end things with the new Ahsoka trailer footage
completely different series but set during the
similar timeline of the Mandalorian five years
plus after Return of the Jedi it seems like in
this footage Ahsoka has come to the ruins of an
ancient Jedi Temple and is just part of her quest
to find Ezra Bridger and Grand Admiral thrawn if
he's spotted any other Easter eggs in the brand
new trailer footage from all the different series
that they include in this just write it below in
the comments like I said I will do more trailer
videos for everything as we get more footage the
next couple of weeks we are supposed to get what
if season 2 episodes at the beginning of next year
but because we haven't seen a trailer yet it might
not Premiere till like February but it is coming
and speaking of Pedro Pascal the Mandalorian
season 3 he's also starring as Joel In The
Last of Us HBO episodes I'll be doing videos for
those episodes we're also getting the little bear
from Game of Thrones as a version of Ellie during
that there's a bunch of really big stuff coming up
make sure you enable alerts for my channel so you
don't miss anything everyone click here for the
full Loki Season 2 trailer and click here here for
my Henry Cavill Warhammer trailer video in Easter
eggs thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and I'll see you guys in the next one!